[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola como estan mi nombre es maria luisa
pineda pero en realidad mis amigos me
dicen mariluz
pero pregunte cómo están
han comido algo afuera o no
y entonces están bien o no
ok les cuento que yo he visto muchas
charlas ted y la verdad es que jamás
pensé que pasaría esto
y en realidad me siento yo también super
feliz alegre por estar aquí pero al
mismo tiempo siento como este nudo en el
estómago
pero ya seguir conviviendo no hay
problema de esta emoción que me embarga
por estar aquí
y como no me quiero sentir sola en este
escenario voy a pedir que alguien me
acompañe aquí no voy a invitar a alguien
y es
ella o sea yo
pero hace unos 30 años más o menos en
esos ojitos no
y esos cachetes que ya no están esos
ojitos llenos de curiosidad y de
inocencia de niño tal vez y creo que ese
día era super importante era tal vez mi
primera foto yo creo que estaba súper
emocionada ese día
le he invitado y le ha invitado este día
aquí conmigo porque ella me va a
recordar de muchas cosas que jamás debe
olvidar
bueno desde esa época yo sabía que mi
vocación era ser arquitecto
mi familia mi papá es ingeniero civil mi
mama inmersa en el mundo de la
construcción todos mis tíos y mis tías
son arquitectos e ingenieros mi padrino
es arquitecto entonces yo tenía barbies
muñecas carritos etcétera pero mis
juegos preferidos eran ir los sábados a
obra y trepar me la excavadora y simular
que estaba destruyendo construyendo
cosas y luego subirme a los montículos
de tierra sacar piedras o subirme a los
techos que estaban por vaciar
luego ya sentía que todo lo tenía
planificado yo ya ser arquitecta desde
siempre jamás había otra cosa en mi
mente entonces ingresé a la universidad
y mi corazón se llenó de emoción porque
estaba empezando a diseñar está
empezando a transformar ciudades
a crear cosas nuevas
como les digo nunca pensé en otra cosa
más terminé la carrera mi corazón está
así ya ahorita voy a empezar a diseñar
en las ciudades y cambiar cosas y de
pronto mi asesor de tesis se me acerca
un día y me dice oye mariluz
o quisieras acompañarnos como profesor
mi mente dijo profesora yo jamás
y de pronto tal vez un porcentaje de
esos ojitos curiosos de niña me dijeron
cállate un ratito
de pronto me dije a mí misma oye qué
pasaría si lo intentas
de la nada ese qué pasaría si lo
intentas me abrió una puerta un umbral
algo que jamás considere aparte de ser
arquitecta me convertí en profesora
pase de un jamás a un qué pasaría si lo
intentó
aún hoy esto me está gustando
todo andaba super bien así increíble
empecé mi época profesional como
arquitecta estaba diseñando tenía un
buen trabajo estaba enseñando en mi
facultad las emoción no podía ver en
realidad
mi familia estaba súper contenta súper
orgullosa me apoyaba en todo hasta mis
tres gatos estaban gorditos rechonchos y
ronronea van cada vez que se tomaban
foto conmigo todo andaba perfecto
y de pronto
un jamás terrible sucede
uno de esos terremotos
acuden la estructura por completo
y es que un martes un martes cualquiera
un martes cualquiera por la mañana
mamá cae al vacío de la escalera
en casa somos tres
y en ese día estábamos los tres
mi papá no sabía qué hacer
yo solamente atinó a gritar corrí en
contra el teléfono y empecé a hacer
llamadas
sentí que el tiempo se dilataba más y
más y la ayuda no llegaba jamás
y silencio sentí caos
sentí algo que jamás había pensado
tal vez y ese día perdí a mi mamá
todo ese caos
que 2
tensión también
de pronto
los médicos decían que
las flores que mi mamá no iba a
sobrevivir
para unas horas y de pronto otro jamás
sucedió uno que los médicos
pensaban
inexplicablemente el corte en el cráneo
de mi mamá empezó a cerrarse
los coágulos empezaron a disminuir de
tamaño
de pronto mi mamá se convirtió en un
milagro
ella volvió a nacer
y nosotros con ella
como esta parte de nuevo después de un
terrible hamás
cómo
hacerlo
seguro que varios de nosotros hemos
sufrido uno de estos terremotos
no me pregunte y ahora qué
ahora qué
entonces decidí volver a mi rutina dije
ya bueno ya están mejorando voy a seguir
con mis clases voy a seguir con mi
trabajo
pero los terremotos dejan huella
y ésta dejó grandes grietas en mí
solamente física sino también
emocionales
entonces decidí buscar ayuda empecé a
preguntarle a la gente a mis amigos a mi
doctor de siempre y de pronto entre
tantas conversaciones salió y
mencionaron por ahí yoga
la primera clase de yo que fui me quedé
dormida en serio jamás voy a volver a
una sesión de yoga
pero de pronto en otra sesión escuché
como el profesor creo que media dormida
oye
tienes que disfrutar el proceso
esa frase quedó marcada en mí
decidí agregar esta hora de yoga a todos
mis días a mi rutina de pronto empecé a
buscar más en mi a reencontrarme con
algunas cosas porque yo me sentía
perdida ya no me sentía yo
es hacer conexiones y de pronto empecé a
conectarme
ya que está aquí pero que también está
aquí
y así mágicamente como empezaron a
suceder las cosas también apareció
alguien
este alguien se me acerca y me dice oye
mariluz cuando tú estás en la
universidad de acuerdo que alguna vez me
dijiste que querías ir al viaje de china
y japón- y yo que como cuando fue baile
1 file 2 dónde estás y de pronto mis
ojos de niña empezaron a abrirse más y
más y más y de la nada dije si yo quiero
ir
y pase un segundo y después dije oye tu
mamá
a esta recuperación
hoy con mi mamá y mamá me dice hija
hazlo
porque tal vez jamás se te vuelva a
aparecer una oportunidad así
ese fue un momento clave otro jamás
demolido un jamás que me hizo reconectar
con mi corazón de arquitecta y no
solamente eso me hizo de alguna manera
volver a sentirme niña
y empecé a correr por todos los
edificios empecé a tocar paredes a oler
cosas diferentes a abrazar columnas
eran increíbles para mí
entonces empecé a darme cuenta que esto
era mágico no y cuando volví decidí
cambiar más jamás a más que pasaría así
entonces lo llevé a todo dije a ver qué
pasa si coloco estas cosas de mis clases
y dije qué pasaría si
retomo mi época de bajista y le digo a
los estudiantes para que interpretemos
conceptos musicales y diseñamos cosas
y luego dije oye y qué pasaría si
en esta época de cómics analizamos
superhéroes y villanos y les hacemos un
pabellón de containers que los
represente
pero qué pasaría si en mi clase de
historia de la arquitectura en vez de
hacerlo es una práctica calificada de
esa y de mucha información en realidad
mejor hacemos un instagram para estos
arquitectos eclécticos del siglo 19
y allá qué pasaría si por fin me saco el
clavo y hago una investigación propia de
un edificio que tanto me encanta de la
historia la arquitectura que jamás se
construyó en el siglo 18 y lo conecto
con los conceptos de esta arma letal la
más increíble de una galaxia muy muy muy
lejana
de la estrella de la muerte de star wars
y dije oye tal vez y lo importante es
conectarnos con esta emoción que te
estructura y ver qué hacer con ella
tal vez y toda esta emoción fue hacer
algo y cambiar éste jamás aún qué
pasaría si abriendo posibilidades
abriendo nuevas opciones
así fue que un día dije y por qué no
hacemos conexiones con conceptos que
también están cerca pero
nadie lo pensó antes porque no hacemos
yoga en clase
y así sentimos lo que realmente siente
un edificio porque nosotros también
somos arquitectura y estructura no
yo creo que eso me trajo aquí
y ahora me pongo a pensar qué pasaría si
nos ponemos todos de pie
estoy hablando de serie
[Música]
a ver todos de pie
allí al fondo se están quedando sentados
ponemos los pies al ancho de caderas no
eres calderón es acá el eje
llevamos los hombros hacia arriba y
hacia atrás
y entonces les de ella no es cierto
y ahora vamos a colocar nuestra mano
izquierda sobre el corazón la mano
derecha en el estómago cuál es tu
izquierda
inhala
infla el estómago
exhala bota todo
nuevamente
la gota todo
ahora vas a colocar tu pie izquierdo en
tu talón derecho
el talón no más no se preocupen si te
sientes cómodo puedes llevarlo un
poquito más arriba
no importa si te balancea si te caes a
lo mismo solo respira que te estás
poniendo morado
y en la siguiente exhalación suelta y
ahora vamos a hacerlo del otro lado
inhala con tu pie derecho al tobillo
izquierdo sube un poquito más tú puedes
la siguiente inhalación vas a llevar tus
brazos hacia arriba
y te abres y si hay un vecino te
conectas toma sus brazos
y exhala suelta bravísimo
[Aplausos]
qué bonitos elegidos
bueno lo que hemos hecho ahora es la
postura del árbol o brics asana
esta postura del árbol es una postura de
balance que nos conecta con nuestras
raíces con nuestros cimientos así como
la arquitectura de un árbol nosotros
también somos una arquitectura que puede
tener unos cimientos muy fuertes y que
crece y de alguna manera se abre no
hacia los demás ya nuevas posibilidades
y podemos construir nos y reconstruir
nos dentro de esta misma estructura
jamás pensaron hacer yoga en techno
e
pasaría si el mundo se hubiese quedado
con él jamás
por ejemplo
construir las tres pirámides más grandes
del mundo y que se conecten con el cielo
jamás
o
tal vez hacer un edificio completamente
de fierro y que se convierta
en un símbolo de este país para el mundo
jamás
ok o volar ir al espacio exterior
ir a la luna diseñar para amarte jamás
ok ya me fui muy lejos más cerca
tal vez construir en la selva
con montaña con una estructura una
fortaleza super fuerte y potente
hamas no
tal vez los jamás nos protegen
algunos nos remecen como terremotos
pero también nos dan la posibilidad de
ver qué pasaría así
a mí
acaso un gran terremoto como el de mi
madre
me hizo fortalecer mis cimientos
reestructurar me tal vez agregando
detalles que no pensé que iba a incluir
dentro de mí
también derribando un jamás descubrí una
de mis más grandes pasiones enseñar
porque para mí enseñar va de la mano con
que pasaría así
para mí enseñar es compartir desde el
corazón
y en el corazón se encuentra esta
emoción de esta energía hermosa que nos
conecta a todos
la verdad es que cuando
vemos todas estas posibilidades podemos
vernos a nosotros mismos
pero como nosotros desde lo cotidiano
viendo desde otro ángulo desde nuestras
raíces peruanas
a través de ojos de niño
podemos transformar el mundo gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]